Oh là là… Qu’est-ce qu’il fait chaud !
Même à l’ombre dans mon jardin,
je n’arrête pas de transpirer.
Pas vous ?
Et en plus, je suis rouge écarlate !
Pire qu’après un marathon…
Allez ! On bouge ? On va se mettre au frais dans l’atelier.
He ! Faut pas rester ici, il fait trop chaud !
L’Homme est homéotherme.
Ce qui signifie que notre température interne
reste toujours la même. Aux alentours de 37°C.
C’est pour cette raison que l’hiver, nous frissonnons quand notre température descend en-dessous de 37°C.
Ces frissonnements se traduisent
par la contraction des muscles.
Ce mouvement génère de la chaleur
qui fait remonter notre température interne.
Ça arrive aussi l’été, quand on nous glisse
un glaçon dans le cou par exemple.
Oh là là… C’est froid !
L’été, quand il fait chaud et que notre température interne grimpe, nous transpirons ;
ce qui permet d’évacuer la chaleur et de revenir à 37°C.
Pourquoi 37°C ?
Vous le savez, notre organisme
est constitué de cellules.
Des centaines de milliards qui fonctionnent
comme autant de petites usines.
Elles transforment les aliments,
produisent des protéines, fabriquent de l’énergie…
Comme le moteur d’une voiture, elles sont performantes à une certaine température, en l’occurrence 37°C.
En-dessous ou au-dessus, elles ne fonctionnent pas correctement et l‘organisme en souffre.
Ça va, ça ne chauffe pas trop ? Alors poursuivons…
Quand il fait chaud, justement, nous transpirons.
Mais attention ! Ce n’est pas parce que la sueur
est froide qu’elle nous rafraîchit.
Elle est même à la même température que notre corps.
D’abord... qui ouvre les vannes ?
Ah c’est malin !
Nous sommes équipés d’un thermostat
situé au cœur du cerveau.
Si, si, c’est un cerveau.
Dans l’hypothalamus.
Dès que la température franchit la barre des 37°C,
le cerveau envoie un signal qui déclenche
la dilatation des vaisseaux sanguins.
C’est pour cette raison
que tout à l’heure j’étais tout rouge.
En se dilatant, les vaisseaux sanguins
augmentent leur surface d’échange avec l’extérieur
ce qui leur permet d’évacuer plus facilement la chaleur.
Parallèlement, les glandes sudoripares,
situées dans le derme,
se remplissent d’eau qu’elles pompent dans nos tissus et l’évacuent vers l’extérieur.
La sueur sort par les pores.
Vous savez ces petits trous
disséminés à la surface de la peau.
Comme je l’ai dit tout à l’heure, cette sueur
est à la même température que les tissus d’où elle sort.
Alors comment fait-elle pour nous refroidir ?
La sueur est essentiellement constituée d’eau liquide.
Des molécules H2O qui s’attirent les unes les autres,
un peu comme des aimants.
Une fois sur la peau, elles s’évaporent.
Très concrètement, les molécules
se détachent les unes des autres.
L’eau passe de l’état liquide à l’état gazeux.
Mais pour cela, les molécules ont besoin d’énergie.
Elles captent de la chaleur
dans nos tissus… qui refroidissent.
Ce n’est donc pas la transpiration qui nous fait refroidir mais l’évaporation de la sueur.
Et c’est d’ailleurs pour cette raison que nous frissonnons quand nous sortons de la douche.
L’eau qui ruisselle sur notre corps
n’est pas froide, au contraire.
Mais elle puise de la chaleur
dans nos tissus pour s’évaporer.
Du coup, on frissonne.
Même chose avec une bombe aérosol.
L’eau nous rafraîchit parce qu’elle puise
de la chaleur dans nos tissus pour s’évaporer.
C’est clair ?
Bah vous avez de la chance !
Parce que moi... je n’y vois plus rien du tout !
En tout cas je me sens mieux…
Enfin façon de parler !
Parce question odeur, la transpiration
ce n’est pas ce qui se fait de mieux.
En fait, ce n’est pas la sueur qui sent mauvais,
c’est sa dégradation.
Surtout celle qui est produite au niveau des aisselles.
Elle contient des nutriments dont raffolent les bactéries qui se développent à la surface de la peau à cet endroit.
Eh bien elles ont du faire un festin !
Je vais peut-être aller prendre une petite douche moi !
Ah ! J’oubliais… En temps normal,
nous produisons 1 litre de sueur par jour.
Mais quand il fait très chaud, comme aujourd’hui,
ou quand nous faisons du sport,
ça peut aller jusqu’à 8 litres.
De l’eau qu’il faut absolument renouveler
si l’on veut être en capacité de refroidir notre organisme.
Et je ne compte pas toute l’eau que nous évacuons
en parlant ou en urinant.
Allez ! À la vôtre...
Et maintenant, à la douche.
Sinon je vais me prendre un savon par la petite caméra !
Nous produisons en moyenne 1 litre de sueur par jour...
Non pas en moyenne...en temps normal !
Ah j'oubl... Je l'ai senti !
Oh bah non ! Pfffff
La sueur est ex... Pfffffff!
Non c'était de l'autre côté !